This is Twit.
Being in the print industry, we get hundreds of jobs coming through,
and you have to review each one and figure out what's going on with it,
and is the file set up correctly and those kind of things.
And I was always looking for ways to automate that process.
So I got into, you know, working with Quark extension developers,
and that helped automate it some.
But then in 1993, I saw an ad in the Apple developer brochure about this amazing English-like language that could control the action of the computers and the apps that are on it.
So I sent in the money and I paid an extra $15 for a scriptable finder, which came on like a 400K floppy, right?
Was this from Apple or a third party?
This was from Apple.
And so I got the AppleScript disk, and at that time, the app that was really powerful, that was scriptable, was QuarkXPress.
Which was used for page layout.
Yes.
It took over from PageMaker.
Yeah, pretty much took over.
All this PageMaker was the dominant program, but right about that time, Quark kind of took over.
Dave Shaver and Ralph Risch had implemented Apple Event Scripting, AppleScript, in QuarkXPress with Tim Gill's help.
Right.
right And so I remember it was in the evening, was after the day and I was sitting there alone
at night and I'm going through this, trying to figure out what this is all about. And it says,
okay, there's a dictionary and this should be called a box. And then, okay, it has properties.
All right. So I write my first script. So I selected a box. And you've not been a programmer
in the past. No, no programming at all. no programming at all. And I drew out a box and
was set the color of the current box to blue you remember it i remember it it's infused in my brain
and i ran that and that box changed Boing and i really yeah yes at that point i let go all my
clients i would had a business doing you know desktop publishing design business and i let go
all my clients and i just focused on learning everything i could possibly learn about AppleScript
that just because you loved it or did you see a like you see how it could be used what was it
that got you it it hit a profound concept within me it opened up a profound concept that has stayed
with me my entire professional life which is that the power of the computer should reside
in the hands of the one using it i don't have to go to a developer and say please can you make this
so that this does this or can you alter your application so that i can do this it put all that
power in my hands and for me that was an awakening and after that i started developing automation
around the print industry because i was in it and i expanded out into other industries too like
media production and video production to automate them. And Apple noticed me because I was writing
books on the topic and I'd be at the same trade shows as them. And my audience would be the Apple
employees standing there watching this. Because they probably didn't know all the things you could
do with this stuff. There was maybe a handful of guys that knew it was in the system, but they
would stand there and eventually they started to ask me, would I join? And I said, well, why should
I'd join. I'd take a 50% pay cut to work for you. I don't want to do that. And then over a period of
time, about a year, it was a group effort by Shafaa Syed, Bamandara, and Guy Kawasaki, and a
couple other people, and Chris Espinoza. They got me on board at Apple, and I joined at like the
worst time. Steve had left. Yeah, I joined in January of 97. So Apple had the word beleaguered
tattooed. This is the beleaguered years. And if you look at where I was hired, I was hired in
January. And at one point, Apple put out these boards on campus that all the employees could see
had a list of every Apple employee and when in order of their hiring. And so there was like
boards around campus and everybody was walking around looking for their name, right? And I was
over here like on board number two. And if you look after my name, then it's like Craig Feguerini
and Avi and all the next guys. Yeah. So I was like the last hire, one of the last hires
before everything opened up. And so automation to me came from a very personal basis. I was always
from the the aspect of getting stuff done in the real world and that knowledge about what
customers needed and how it gets used in the end was essential to my role at Apple when i came on
board to you know to protect this technology because at that time Apple script was not
part of the operating system
you